Okay, so now we move into your budget presentation.
You thank you.
I'll be quick. So this is the budget presentations for
Finance Department. You should
have a handout in front of you.
Before I begin the first slide, please let
me quickly introduce the key players in the Finance Department. I know you've
met William Jones. You may already
interacted with some of these excellent team players in
this Finance Department supporting me in leading this department.
I just want to make sure we have the slides.
Okay, well, while we're waiting on
that, I know you have your handout. That will be slide two. In your
handout, we have six divisions in the Finance
departments. Again. From the director's office, we have Bernita
Jones. I don't know if she's here. If not,
so if I call your name, please do stand up so that I don't have
to look back. So we have Fernita Jones,
who of course you all met and very familiar who support
the Council's Office. We have Rochelle McHenry.
Anushi is here. Thanks Rochelle. She supported
the Houston fire departments. We also have William Bryan,
who support the Houston Information Technology. Thank you,
William. We have Sheila Murphy, who also supported
the business office in the finance department. Thank you.
The next division is Treasury Capital Management. Of course, you all know Melissa Dubovsky,
who's not here today. We also have financial planning
analysis. William Jones, who you've met.
The next one is the financial reporting and operations by
Are sheet. Just want to make sure you know the
face and the name together. And, of course, we have the strategic
procurement divisions. Jerry Adams.
There you go. Our chief procurement officer. And last but
not least is the Performance improvement, Jesse Bounds. If he's
here, the computer froze in the back.
So just keep working. Okay, so again, Finance Departments has
two funds. So we have the general fund
for Citywide Surfaces as well as the revolving fund,
which is a surface chargeback for financial services provided to
certain departments. So with that, we are moving to the
next slide. Slide number three, if you can, flip your
page again on the Functional Organization charts chart.
In the general fund, the finance budget is at 20.8 million
with 116 FTEs in this. So again,
you saw the functional indirector's office from the
Council Administration's, legislative Analysis,
TPIA Coordinations, the Treasury Capital
Management at 2.9 million. This is the
area that handles the capital budget, planning,
management, reporting and Analysis, the debt issuance and Derivative
monitoring, economic Modeling and Projection,
the City's financial alternative,
liquidity alternatives, tax and Revenues Management.
I know Melissa often would come before councils to
give a presentation on upcoming financial transactions.
That division also handles the OPEP and pension
system analysis, financial planning analysis.
Budget at 2.5 million. Again, this is FTEs at
16. But as you saw, we have very limited
active employees at this point. Again,
that division handling the citywide annual operating budget, the five year forecast,
providing revenues and expenditures projections. We have the monthly
financial reporting, mid year review, funds management
and any ad hoc financial reporting the next
on the financial reporting operations. So again, this is a broad mix of
Citywat Accounting and reporting operations from the Accounting
Disaster Recovery to Fixed assets Management, grants Management
including the trust Funds management and Accounts Receivable
is at $6 million. Budget at
29.2 FTEs. Strategic Procurement of course,
as the name implies, handling the Citywide procurement,
administrations Material Vendor Contract Management,
peacock Administrations budget at 5.9
million at 44.7 FTEs.
And again we have the Performance Improvement divisions in
here at 440,000. This is the Office of Innovations that
deals with the citywide operational process improvement from citywide
data analytics to smart city program management.
Continuing on to the next slide, which is the revolving fund.
This is budgeted at 7.5 million at 60.2
FTEs. Again this slide.
It provides financial services to fleet hits
fire departments, grants management for Housing
department. This fund also handles the Citywide
Energy Financial Management as well as accounts payable function
for certain departments. Director's Office budget
at 1.4 million. This is the Fiscal Administrators
to oversee the financial management for Hits and Fire departments.
That includes the annual budget, monthly financial report and
any ad hoc financial analysis. And in
the treasury and Capital Management budget at 267,000.
This is only two FTEs in here supporting client departments
for Capital Planning and cost benefit analysis.
This is for Fleet Hits and Fire
as our client departments for the Capital Management
financial planning analysis at 885.5
thousand. This is at 5.3 FTEs.
This is handling the Energy Financial Management supporting
the fleet Departments sorry, Energy Financial
Management for GSD and also supporting the Fleet Managements
in their operating annual budget and monthly financial report.
Strategic procurement at 1.3 million.
We have 9.9 FTEs in here. This is again
supporting the procurement for Fleets, Hits and Fire departments.
One thing I want to note on the financial reporting operations,
I don't know if I think I probably missed it. Financial reporting
operations at 3.6 million. This is handling the Invoice reconciliations and
payments for several departments including Hits, Public Works,
Fire Departments and Planning as well as the payment on
the Energy Management, that is the electricity and natural gas bills
that we have to pay as well as the service chargeback processing
including the EMS Billing. That is all in this revolving fund.
Moving on to the next slide. Slide five again.
I'm just going to go briefly again. You all know what we do in the
Finance Department. This is the major services in the Finance departments is
managing the Citywide Debt and Capital Management budgeting forecasting,
citywide Energy Contracts, financial Reporting and Auditing,
grants Management Oversight, Disaster Recovery as you're
all aware, as well as the Cdwat procurement.
Next slide on the statutory requirements
for service delivery. I want to stress
out, we do have to comply with the statute requirements
for what we do in the Finance Department, that is from ensuring compliance
with the Texas Tax Code and Propositions One and
H to make sure that the city present a balanced budget in accordance
with state law and financial policies. We also have to follow the federal
and state compliance, including the procurement law that
we have to out comply and also completion of the annual
financial and single audit, again to be in compliance with the
state and federal laws. So again, any mismanagement
of these functions will be impacting the cities tremendously from
uninformed decisions from you all and the mayor's procurement failure
that will impact the surface delivery and city operations,
to claw back the federal funds and even to defaulting of
the city debt. So it is important for us in our function
in the finance departments to comply with all of these laws
for the sustainability of the city's operations.
So let's start looking into the numbers at this point.
I know we don't have the slides. So again, slide seven.
So on the General fund, again, we have 2.1
billion. The bulk of the property tax and sales tax is in the Finance Department's
business area, $2.1 billion
general fund in fiscal year 23, which is
51.5 million higher compared to the fiscal year 22
estimates. That is about 2.5% increase. I know
we've went a great deal in the budget overview on the property tax
and sales tax as we
saw it initially. Again, to keep in mind,
property tax and sales tax alone is comprised about 98.7%
of the financial revenues in
the revolving fund. We have about 7.5 million in here, but again,
this is a surface chargeback so it is essential revenues as we
recover the cost of providing financial services to this department.
So the next slide, slide eight is going through the details again.
Again, as we mentioned, our property tax is at $1.28
billion, reflect an increase of 48.9 million
compared to fiscal year 22 estimates. Again, this is
based on the Propositions One and H and again,
this is based on the CPI inflation rate of 4.28%
and 0% growth of populations on
the sales tax. Again, we've covered this before,
our sales tax revenues is at $807,000,000,
which is assuming no growth at this point. Again, we continue
to monitor. We've seen some upticks in fiscal year 2022,
but again, with so many uncertainties and even going through the consultant
review, we felt that it's probably best to just keep it
flat at this point because of those uncertainties in the inflations for
fiscal year 23 budget for mixed beverage taxes at 20.7 million
reflects about $570,000 increase from fiscal year 22
estimates. Next slide,
which is slide nine, this is the expenditure site on the again,
a combined budget that we have in fiscal year 23 is
about 28.3 million. 20.8 million
is for General Fund and 7.5 of that is for
thank you revolving Fund.
So we'll go through the details in the next slide.
Slide ten thank you.
So, slide ten, this is just again the compositions on
the general fund for the personnel versus non
personnel. Again, personnel compress about 76%
in the general fund of 15.8 million and
24% or 5 million is the non personnel of
which if you look at the pie charts on the right
that comprise of billing collections about 1.3
million. So that is the billing collections where we
pay for the Harris County tax office for the property tax collected.
We also have an audit, auditing contracts 1.6 million.
This is with the auditing contracts for
the year end audit that we work closely with the controller's
office restricted account at 949,000 compressed
about 19% and services which is 1.1 million.
So this is where we have the printing costs, advertising costs,
parking rentals and so some of those consultants
happy with the outcome based budgeting for instance, is all in that services category.
So now we look@the.net change from the fiscal year 22
current budget on the next slide. So let's
start with the operating budget in fiscal year 22 started at 17.9
million. Again with the adjustment as
you saw in the general appropriation, we have restricted account,
hope and health benefits adjustment including the city council surplus
for a one time adjustment that I graciously thank you for Fernita Jones
office. So our fiscal year 22 current budget at
this point with those adjustments at 19 million. So now
moving on to the incremental increases to come up
with our fiscal year 23. So again, that city council surplus
is a one time adjustment. So we took it out this budget,
it does include funding for ten new positions. So I did ask for
funding for ten new positions in my departments. This is
to help assisting the Strategic Procurement Grants
offer site and also capital Management. Again,
with this federal money that we have, we need more
streamlined process and help in those procurement divisions
as well as the Grants offer site. And so with that
our changing from operating budget from
fiscal year 22 reflect about 5.8%. Now I'm going
to move on to restricted account and health benefits and hope pay increases.
So those contractual mandate increases about 621,000.
So in total our budget increased by 1.6
million. So that comprised about 8.6% from the
fiscal year 22 current budget. So those are the details that
increase decrease from fiscal year 22 to fiscal year 23
expenditures budget. Next slide.
Again, I mentioned this briefly when we go through the net
change again, our budget includes for both
General fund and revolving fund, includes funding for health benefits,
pension contributions and the 3% hope pay increases.
Again in general fund it does include funding for ten new employees,
new positions to keep up with the increasing workload.
This is dealing with the Strategic procurement and the grants management as well as the
capital and debt functions revolving fund. Again, this is just to
provide funding for financial procurement
and accounts payable receivable support to hit Fleet and
Fire, as well as the
energy management. Again, it's very straightforward.
I think that's the end of my presentations and I'm open for any questions.
Thank you, council Member Abby Cayman. Thank you,
Director Emo. Again, I just wanted to thank you for all the
work you and your team do, and even in other
efforts that we as council are undertaking,
we come to you and you're always willing to help us and support us.
So thank you for making our jobs a lot easier.
I'm going to be asking this question of every department.
Given the significant budget constraints
that the city continues to face, are there priority
items that your department is not going to
be getting in this budget?
If not be getting yeah,
thank you for asking that question. So, one thing's first.
With the Pandemic and a lot of the grants funding we have,
the first party I ask for the mayor, is to make sure that we have
enough resources to carry those reporting
and making sure that federal monies are spent in compliance.
So I am gracious enough to get those decisions funded,
as you see in this budget, and that includes the procurement groups.
Again, we handle city wide functions in here
from the grants offer side and the procurement. So I
think I don't have anything else at
this point. Again, it may change because,
again, we've talked about great resignations and competitiveness
with the market. And I think, again, this is happening in all across the
board, that everybody's seeing that. And so I may come
then. But at this point, since this is the start of the fiscal year,
I have been graciously granted those funding.
Thank you, Council Member Ed Pollard.
Thank you, Mayor Pro Tim. And sorry if these questions were asked
earlier, but I just wanted to kind of get a general overview
for the public on just how financially sound stable
we are currently. I know we throw out a lot of numbers and
this is kind of a high level overview, but for the
general person that's just tuning in, would you
say that the city right now is financially sound?
Yes. So I just want to point out, so for
credit rating agencies to change their
outlook from negative to stable is a great
deal for the items that the
mayor had accomplished with the pension reform and
the OPEC reform. Those credit rating agencies
really recognize the leadership, including you all,
to managing the financials of the city of Houston. So, yes, we are
currently financially sound. Are there any specific shortfalls
that you see that we need to be aware of?
It depends on where we go, where the path we are moving
forward at this point. And I think that's why I stress enough about preserving this
fund balance, because we can be in the path that we should.
Has the administration identified
specific allocations regarding the ARPA dollars
that will be coming in that we need to be aware of.
So I know I mentioned to you about we have $160,000,000
of ARPA funding in here. And I know
Mayor mentioned about the use of the ARPA dollars
for the revenue losses in the next year.
I know there's other projects that have
been presented and I think you all have seen it as well. The ones if
Houston, for example, is part of the ARPA fundings and
I can give you the list, I think we have the ARPA website already open,
so we can give you those details. Well, I want to thank you
again as well for your leadership and your entire team. Thank you for all
the hard work and the long nights. We all appreciate it. So thank
you very much. Thank you. It means a lot. Council Member David Robinson. Thank you,
Mayor Protem. And following on the line of my two colleagues with their last questions,
I just want to say thank you for everything you're doing. I think this is
a good wrap up to the last two days where we've heard from you,
from the mayor in particular. And I know a moment ago when
you were acknowledging your staff, who we all feel very strongly about, great job,
everyone. You mentioned Vernita Jones, who was not in the chamber
at the time, and Vernita is here. So I just wanted to call
particular attention to her because she does a great job across the street taking
care of us and
our budgets for all our people. And to the point about impact
of the great resignation, I know she's had a lot
of work to do for a number of our offices. So I just wanted
to ask you one follow up question to that. I don't know if she heard
it. When she was absent, did you mean that you were zeroing out her
budget? Is that right? I find that hard
to believe. No. Okay. All right, thanks.
Council Member Sally Alcorn. Thank you.
And good for you for getting the ten new positions. I know you need them.
In the big book, you mentioned as one of your performance measures
getting in compliance with our financial policies 100%.
I just see that we're out of compliance on just two of them. One has
to do with internal controls and one on our credit rating.
Can you explain a little bit further about how we're going to come in compliance
with that? I think on the structurally balanced budget stuff, it's in progress,
but those two were out of compliance. So can
you talk about that? Yeah. So keep in mind when
we have that and we keep our bar high,
which is good. When we did the financial policy, I think
it was based on fiscal year 2014, if I'm not mistaken.
And a lot happened from fiscal year 2014 to now.
So there was a time when we did get downgraded and I can't remember which
one. And I think, like I said, we were having a negative outlook
and so now we're moving back up. So we are in the right path just
by that change from negative to stable.
Let's start the change of the credit rating does not come overnight.
So it takes some steps because they want to make sure how you run in
that year and then the next year then they will change it. And so now
the fact that we change from the negative to stable is good. So the next
hope is with all this preserve fund balance, hopefully we would get those
additional increase in the credit rating so that we can go back to the compliance
compared to fiscal year 14. On the risk assessment,
there was part of our budget reductions, to be honest with you, with the internal
audit, again, during fiscal year 14 to now, a lot of things happen.
The economy landscape has changed. So there was budget reductions
on the internal audit, so there was out of compliance. So we
are going back to see what we can do to put it back
in the compliance state. Okay, great. And I have some questions on
specific line items within general government and you're the appropriate person to
send those to correct? I mean, you can do that. I can
tell you the dollars on what so some of the operating
questions are probably will have to defer, but okay, we'll do those in writing.
Thank you. Thank you. And there are no other council members in queue.
And I made these comments yesterday.
The City of Houston budget is made up by the administration,
you and your staff and the mayor and presented to us and we make
amendments to it. But our final vote is either yes or no. We either
accept it or we reject it. I think this
budget is in the best shape of any budget I dealt with in my
nine years here. And it's because of you and your team and the
diligence that we put forward a year ago when we saw sales
tax revenue and a lot of our revenue gone down and we
made some specific budgetary cuts and
we see the good of those. So thanks for your leadership,
always enjoy working with you and your deputy
directors, mr. Jones and Ms. Dabowski, and your entire team. You all do
a great job day in and day out in a tough environment and thanks
for everything you do. And I do believe this budget process is
hopefully going to be one of the smoothest ones we see because of some of
the pain that you saw coming and you made adjustments,
you and your team. So thanks for that. We do have three virtual public speakers.
The first is Saba Blanding star
Six. Again, Ms. Blanding.
Star six. There you go.
Yes. Okay. There I'm unmuted. Can you hear me okay?
Yes. Wonderful.
I have a question kind of two sides of probably the
same coin. You mentioned the high number of Vacancies going into
the budget cycle. Why is
retention an issue for your department beyond
the great resignation and how can we improve it?
And then kind of alongside that and maybe kindred
to what council member came in, asked earlier. I'm just really curious,
in a perfect world, how many employees does
your department need ideally? Like what would be the perfect number
and what type of kind of similar to this, what type of pay increases
would there be ideally? So I have a more pragmatic question about
Vacancies and retention and improving it
and then just kind of I would like to know the ideal
number of employees so we can kind of know the difference between what's
happening and what is needed.
Okay, so it's
an interesting question. Let's start with the Vacancies at this point.
So we are in the general fund departments, and you've
gone through the budget presentations with our limited revenue sources.
And so we have to continuously looking for efficiencies
and process improvements in the finance and city department.
Citywide, what happened with the
Pandemic? I think it changed and I think you probably know this too, it changed
the landscape of the global mindset of
employees and employer too, right? So some
private sectors can provide those flexibilities that we don't
at the city of Houston, right? Because the work is different.
We have people who have to be here meeting citizens.
And the pay the market study,
again, it's hard to compete
with the private sectors. Of course, when you do a market study, you compare with
the same government, municipal employees.
And so we continuously looking at that. And of course it's a
vicious cycle, if I can say. The more work you do, the more burned
out you are, and then the more you are looking for other position elsewhere.
And so that's what happened. Retentions at the same time, because you
don't have enough people and you are overworked pay
increases, an ideal number of people.
And I can go back on the previous years
when we don't have any all of these cuts and to see what those
numbers are, you're probably looking at back in 2010 or
I mean 2008, if anything. Right. And I have to look at this FTEs
number. But those are difficult
situations to handle at this point, especially when you deal with the competitiveness with
the market. Thank you, jason Oliver,
before, there has been conversation about
unmet needs I'm really kind of interested in
because some departments come up and they say we're not able to do X,
Y and Z because of the limitations or because of the
cuts that we've made. And I'm less clear on how
that is working with the finance department.
So I'm interested and I'm curious about these kind of unmet needs for
finance. And then you had talked about a market
study comparing to municipal employees. You said
that we had kind of leveled out legal. And I'm wondering if we
are competitive if we're looking at municipal finance
employees. And I wanted to circle back to the outcomes
based budgeting because I'm
interested in if it's possible, like will you modify
your you had talked about changing your budget calendar during the last presentation,
so I'm wondering if you'll be modifying
it to better incorporate public input. For example,
many cities hold public workshops both before and
after a proposed budget is released to really get the community knowledgeable
about what's in there and make sure that their priorities are included.
So three things. First is unmet needs. Second,
competitive based on municipal employees. And then third,
about modifying the budget calendar as we shift
to outcomes based budgeting. Can you say the first
one again? Unmet needs. Unmet needs.
Okay, thank you. So again, I mentioned in
some of my slide on the finance departments, what we do in
the finance department is a
lot of that is actually compliance with the
state and federal regulations. Right? You're talking about the
procurement, talking about, again,
the debt management making sure that we are not mismanaging
those and you don't want to have any stations when we are at the default.
At this point, the budget, which is again is governed
in the state and local policies and
again the grants disaster recovery.
What we do is essentially essential to
the city. And so I cannot say that I would not be
meeting those functions because it's
a must in that sense.
So, yeah, I cannot say that I cannot meet
any demands because the function that we do are
directly affecting out of
compliance of the city to the state and
local charter. So the impact is
maybe, I don't know, maybe a late payment if that is the case. But of
course it bites you back because then you have to pay late fees.
For example, going back to your comment, it's not unmet
needs, but I probably will have a delay if I don't have enough people in
the procurements. But you don't want to have a wrong product
being delivered or you don't want to have a wrong scope being written.
So again, those expertise in my area
is very crucial because what we do is going to be affecting
the entire city's operations. So I cannot stress
enough the city wide functions that our departments handles.
So the last comment you have is the outcome based budgeting we
will have. And I think Mr. Jones had mentioned to you we
do have the Plan Houston process, and I
think the input that we want from the public is the priorities. Exactly what
do you want to see the city spend the dollars?
The outcome based budgeting is just a vision on how
it's going to look like. But I think the key that you are trying
to get is the input of the public for those priorities.
And I believe that is already in place. But I can double check,
but those are the priorities that need some input from the public.
Thank you. Next speaker is Mr. Doug Smith.
Thank you. I just want to go back to a question I asked earlier
that didn't get answered.
We received $300 million of ARPA funds and
we're going to get another 300 million. And the first 300 million
was used last year. And then this coming budget, if I
understand correctly, but you're addressing the budget gap does
not take into consideration the next 300
million that we're going to receive. So that's one question.
And then is there somewhere how you calculated
the property tax? Because when I look at the projected
increase, it's 3.9% over 2022.
And I thought the state law and I
don't know the state law, but I thought the state law mandated a three
and a half percent increase. So I would like to see how that
calculation was done. And finally,
in the raw data under other interfund services,
which I understand you explained well, there's revenues of $7,400,000.
And where does that revenue appear? If it does appear
in page 625 where you
list all of your revenues, those are my
questions. Okay. So I think
correct me if I'm wrong if I get it right, your questions. The ARPA
dollar that we are receiving or to be received
is $607,000,000. About $303,000,000
has been received last May. Another 303,000,000 will be received
sometimes this month.
This includes the allocations of
ARPA of 160,000,000 at this point. That came
from the first tranche, which is $303,000,000.
Great. Yes. Thank you. That's what I thought. And the
next 300 million, you did not take that into consideration when
you talked about addressing the budget gap.
You said that you didn't include that in what the proposed gap might be.
Is that a correct statement? So the next tranche,
again, we have the one safe Houston. We have other stuff that has already been
included in the ARPA. And I know
I included projected gap for fiscal year 24,
with the hope is to also use the ARPA money then. But again,
that will be from the second tranche. Correct me if I'm wrong.
ARPA funds can be used until December 31,
2023. 424. Got it.
So 24. Okay. For us,
yes. The second questions you have is on,
I believe is it on the property tax calculations?
Yes. Because you're showing a projected 3.9%
increase. And I thought that new state law mandated
a three and a half percent increase. And I just like to understand how
that plays against our own property tax cap.
So I know our proposed budget is including the
4.28% increase of
the CPI, but remember, we also
have the 90 million on the Prop H.
And I can go back to you again to reconcile
the 3.97% versus the 4.23 of
the CPI number, but some of that could be from
the Prop H.
Okay, well, okay. What about the state cap is three.
And a half percent. How does that play into this?
I will have to get back to you on those
details on the calculations. I think there's also some
other annexations maybe included in the fiscal year 22
budget. Again, annexation is only when it's available
and only for twelve months. You don't use annexations every single year.
So maybe some other stuff in the fiscal year 22 estimates.
Just a reminder of any additional questions. If you want to send to District
E at houstontx Gov, we will answer them and get back to you.
A reminder to the council members council members should
submit any department budget workshop questions in a Word document and
we'll upload that to SharePoint and departments have been
directed to provide responses within 48 hours of the conclusion
of their presentation. Department responses will
also be uploaded on SharePoint and give us two
minutes and we'll transition. And my apologies to Chief Pena,
Chief West and Ms. McHenry for the delay.
I'm sure your presentation will be worth it.
So thank you. We will transition and Vice Chair Ed Pollard
will be sitting here two minutes.